what you're looking at is a sketch of a
set which recalled the Brixton music law
for the motion picture star I am Boris
Levin and is our director for the
picture as it as mayores old English
music halls as I could find in designing
the set and constructing this model I
took ideas from several real locations
the rest was imagination I remember this
place I worked here when I was about 14
years old just down the block and
through a little news there's a
marvelous small restaurant you see the
real trick is to give the actors a sense
of reality one of the nominated art
directors does his work in addition to
Boris Levin and set decorators Walter M
Scott and Howard Bristol first are the
nominees for best achievement in art
direction our for Oliver John box and
Terrence Marsh
set decoration Vernon Dixon and Ken
muggle sting for the shoes of the
fisherman George W Davis and Edward
Carfagna for 2001 a Space Odyssey
Tony masters Harry Lange and Ernie
Archer for war and peace Mikhail
Bogdanov and ganodi Mia's Nicole set
decoration G Coachella and V ooh borrow
and the winner the winners are John Bach
and Terrence Marsh
thank you very very much
great day Donna thank you